how many apprentices did jigsaw have the
saw two come before or after saw four if
the continuity has you saying game over
this is the entire saw timeline
explained John Kramer's Sinister Arc
begins with his time as an engineer and
building designer JN works with his
friend Attorney Art blank on creating
low-income housing for needy families
through their urban renewal group Jill
John's wife works at an addiction
recovery Clinic JN is concerned over the
safety of Jill's workplace and his fears
prove to be well-founded when a patient
named Cecil Adams ATT Ms to rob the
facility he shoves a heavy door into
Jill's stomach on the way out causing
her to miscarry Gideon the son she and
JN had been awaiting Cecil had been
encouraged to go to the clinic by Amanda
young a fellow addict and patient who
was once arrested by detective Eric
Matthews John who is waiting for Jill in
his car has a brief encounter with
Addison cord who makes a sexual Advance
Jon turns down John and Jill's
relationship falls apart shortly after
this incident a doll JN is created for
his unborn son later inspires jigsaws
ominous Vis shortly after the decline of
his marriage Jon is diagnosed with
terminal cancer by Dr Lawrence Gordon of
the angel of Mercy Hospital during his
treatment John befriends an orderly
named Zep hindle Zep makes it clear that
he dislikes Dr Gordon Jon is also
treated by Dr Lyn denin his tumor is
deemed to be inoperable because Jon was
diagnosed too late next to an x-ray
labeling error by Logan Nelson John
seeks approval for an alternative
treatment option with insurance
executive William Easton JN is warned he
will lose his coverage with umbrella
Health if he pursues experimental
treatments as the company is quick to
cut off clients in need of care like
cardiac patient Harold Abbott this
decision comes back to haunt Easton you
just given me a death sentence I who's
going to cover me
now you just kill me After experiencing
severe depression Jon drives himself off
a cliff but he survives the crash and
gains a new perspective on life and an
incessant urge to force his Revelation
on others he begins his deadly series of
games with a bit of Retribution
concealing himself with a pig mask and
capturing Cecil out a carnival John
places Cecil in restraints in his lab
and tells him that he has a choice to
either bleed out from the wounds on his
wrists or press his face through a
series of blades if he chooses the
ladder he'll become a scarred on the
outside as he is on the inside but John
insists he'll escape with a renewed
lease on life the tool that's going to
save your
life I want to play a game Cecil is
unable to complete his challenge but
then his chair breaks apart and allows
him to escape Cecil proceeds to attack
Jon but he stumbles into a cage full of
razor wire and dies jigsaw reveals Logan
Nelson to have been Jon's first sidekick
Logan fails to wake up during the
initial Buckethead trap at Tuck's pig
farm and is badly wounded by the blades
but John does not believe Logan has to
die due to his careless but innocent
x-ray mislabeling JN rescues Logan from
the trap and trains him in his
philosophy which Logan finds to be
helpful it is not clear how long Logan
works with Jon but he helps him prepare
some of his earliest traps including the
reverse bear trap we also don't yet know
if he had any relationship with jigsaws
other Sidekicks jigsaws recruitment
spree doesn't stop with Logan Mark
Hoffman is part of the First
Metropolitan Police Department team
investigating the jigsaw murders
alongside detectives David tap Steven
Singh and Allison krey he learns enough
about jigsaw to imitate his methods
pretending to be jigsaw Hoffman gets
Vengeance against Seth Baxter his
sister's murderer via the pendulum trap
so don't call this Karma I call it
justice Hoffman is already known for his
violent and immoral ways he previously
created friction with officer Matt
Gibson after Hoffman shot a man who
attacked Gibson several times even
though the man had disarmed himself
Hoffman was was promoted after the
incident while Gibson was transferred to
Internal Affairs jigsaw does not punish
Hoffman though he does admonish him for
not giving Seth a chance to survive his
trap John offers to take him under his
wing the two then test two other victims
Paul and Mark Hoffman also helps John
frame Dr Gordon by leaving the doctor's
pen light at the scene of Mark's game at
the re warns John that detective tap is
getting close to identifying him tap
narrowly survives a trap laid for the
police but Singh Is killed JN also
recruits Amanda after she survives her
trap and the three work together to
create create several
traps after Amanda agrees to become
jigsaws third Protege she helps John
orchestrate the infamous bathroom trap
she helps kidnap Dr Gordon who is having
an affair with a student and Adam
stanheight a photographer taking
pictures of Gordon for tap Amanda sets
up the room so that jigsaw can play his
Sinister game Gordon wins by sawing off
his own foot and his wife and daughter
also Escape Zep with tap's help Gordon
drags himself through the halls of
jigsaws lirer and finds a hot steam pipe
to cauterize his leg wound jigsaw then
takes Gordon in to help him recover even
devising a prosthetic for his leg Amanda
sneaks back into the bathroom to
asfixiate Adam who's already bleeding
out as an act of Mercy Gordon goes on to
become jigsaw secret helping hand as
revealed in saw the Final Chapter he
assists with some of the more medically
sensitive tests including the Venus fly
trap from Saw 2 and the melum trap from
Saw 4 he also suggests Linn denin as a
test subject in Saw 3 after being told
that his Advanced Brain Tumor will only
leave him a few months to live JN seeks
solace in a cancer support group well
out a Cafe he runs into to support group
member Henry Kesler Henry who testified
to having terminal stage 4 pancreatic
cancer now claims to have been cured
it's all thanks to an experimental
Norwegian cancer treatment conducted by
Dr Finn Peterson this is the
experimental treatment that umbrella
health insurance executive William
Easton turned Jon down for and saw six
eager to get started Jon accepts an
offer of the experimental treatment once
in Mexico Jon is picked up by a taxi
driver named Diego as Diego gives him
the 50 Cent tour of Mexico City they are
ambushed by masked men who take John
away in their unmarked van when the men
take johon to the treatment facility he
is met by Cecilia Peterson the daughter
of Dr Finn Peterson who is now
conducting the treatment she explains
that she needs to take precautions to
stop big Pharma finding her location
Cecilia and John walk the facility
grounds as she explains the procedure to
him along the way he meets Gabriella who
credits Cecilia for saving her life
Valentina the head nurse Mato the
anesthesiologist and Parker Sears an now
cancer-free patient John awakens from
his operation in a different building
with the good news that he has his whole
life ahead of him unfortunately when he
returns to the treatment facility he
makes an earth shattering Discovery the
facility is now empty and the operating
room has been cleared out in a hurry not
wanting to accept the unthinkable he
removes his head bandages only to
discover that he has no scars or signs
of having had brain surgery how much
time do I have months at best
understandably Jon is incensed he flies
into action capturing Diego who is not
only his cabbie but also posed as John's
surgeon passing Jon's test Diego escapes
his trap and happily Nam everyone
involved in the cruel hustle John calls
detective Hoffman for backup instructing
him to help find the charlatans
responsible for selling him and so many
others false hope Amanda arrives to
assist Jon in kidnapping and executing
his new game once everyone is in place
Jon explains the rules to his players
and leaves them to it surprisingly
Cecilia manages to make for a worthy
opponent briefly turning the tables on
Jon and his crew before she ends up in
one final trap in a mid credit scene JN
and detective Hoffman welcome Henry
Kesler to the same disgusting bathroom
that appeared in saw Henry hangs by his
wrist from the ceiling with a strange
mechanical device attached to his torso
John points out that the scar he showed
him is proof of his life saving
operation is no longer there so it's
time to play a game in saw two Jon is
finally identified as the jigsaw killer
Eric Matthews is among the officers who
finds his Hideout little does he know
Jon has kidnapped Matthew's teenage son
Daniel and put him in a group trap at
the nerve gas house alongside Amanda
Addison and several other people who'd
been arrested by Matthews on bogus
charges after most of the subject die
Xavier Chavez attempts to kill Amanda
and Daniel but Daniel defends them and
kills Xavier in the bathroom from the
first film Daniel is then put into a
safe with an oxygen mask and hidden in
jigsaws layer detectives Matthews Carrie
and Daniel rig arrive with others at the
scene of jigsaws lirer and are unaware
that the footage of the group trap they
were presented with was pre-taped
instead of waiting like he is instructed
to Matthews brutalizes John and forces
him to take him to the location of the
Trap while rig discovers that the source
of the video feed is Another Empty House
Matthews ends up alone at the actual
location and is captured and trapped by
Amanda in the bathroom in Saw 3 it is
revealed that Matthews breaks his own
foot to escape the shackle but he's
still captured for another game Saw 3
takes place 6 months after Matthews is
captured John Kramer is near death he
gives his lawyer a box containing
instructions for Jill meanwhile Amanda
is secretly resorting to self-mutilation
and creating unsurvivable traps
including one used on carry Jon has a
true bond with Amanda but doesn't want
to be replaced by a murderer he devises
one last test for her JN has aanda
abduct Dr Lin dlin and put her into a
neck trap dlin is forced to keep Jon
alive for the duration of another test
which turns out to involve her husband
Jeff Lynn and Jeff lost the son and have
emotionally neglected their daughter who
was kidnapped before Jeff's test little
does Amanda know her survival depends on
being able to let denin go hman slightly
tells Amanda to kill denin threatening
to expose her part in Cecil's attack on
Jill's Clinic if she refuses amand Lynn
is more important than you know Amanda
refuses to let denin go and shoots her
instead Jeff enters the room shortly
thereafter and kills Amanda in
retaliation for Jeff's final test Jon
asks him to show Mercy but Jeff cuts his
throat with an electric saw triggering
dlan's collar in saw four it is revealed
that Hoffman was pretending to be
trapped alongside Matthews and art as
the events in John's hospital room
unfolded rig is supposed to let his
timer run out but instead rushes into
the final room with Hoffman Matthews and
art not knowing who's rushing in
Matthews shoots rig and triggers a
device at crushes his own head rig also
shoots art thinking the tape recorder in
his hand is a gun before rig bleeds out
he sees Hoffman reveal himself as
jigsaws Apprentice meanwhile FBI agent
Peter STM and his partner Lindsay Perez
have been following rig's Trail STM
arrives at Jon's room just after Jeff
kills JN St shoots Jeff in apparent
self-defense hofman locks STM in but he
finds an exit however he is then
captured and put into the water Cube
trap St barely survives by using a pen
to perform a tracheotomy on himself
Hoffman then emerges and brings out the
denon's daughter thinking he'll be the
Lone Survivor he stunned to discover St
also made it out alive John's autopsy
reveals a tape that promises Hoffman
will be tested Hoffman later receives a
mysterious note that warns I know who
you are the notes is from Dr Gordon who'
received a tape from Jill's box in which
JN asks him to watch out for Jill STM
determines that Hoffman was jigsaws
Apprentice after reading up on the Seth
bter case despite being removed from the
case by his Superior Dan Erikson he
continues to investigate Hoffman Jill
complains to Erikson that St is stalking
her meanwhile Hoffman Works to set up
stum as a suspect he stages a group trap
involving five crooked people connected
to a deadly apartment fire STM
previously investigated Hoffman also
uses stm's cell phone to lead Ericson to
the location of the group trap upon
finding two victims still alive Ericson
puts out an APB on stom it's all for not
however as Hoffman leads stom to the
nerve gas house and traps him in a room
that crushes him to death Huffman stages
a two-person test for a pair of lone
sharks so he can continue framing stom
Ericson grants Hoffman unfettered access
to the FBI's investigation and reveals
that Perez faked her death and is still
active on the case later Hoffman carries
out jigsaws wish for a test on William
Easton in which Easton is forced to make
life or death decisions for a series of
his employees Easton is not the only one
being tested however the wife and son of
the late heral Abbott must decide
Easton's fate once he reaches the finale
of his test they choose to kill him
though jigsaws work is finally done
Hoffman is not in the clear Ericson and
Perez soon discover Hoffman's identity
as soon as the FBI agents realize who
Hoffman is however he kills them the
last surprise to come from Jon's box for
Jill is the reverse bear trap John's box
instructs Jill to use it on Hoffman
however Hoffman manages to survive the
device meanwhile Jill meets with officer
Gibson and offers to implicate Hoffman
in exchange for immunity and protection
however Hoffman manages to divert police
attention by staging the grizzly
horsepower trap as well as the test of
Bobby denan who was made of Fortune
pretending to be a jigsaw Survivor after
setting a deadly trap for Gibson and
other officers Hoffman manages to sneak
himself into the body bag of one of the
horsepower victims to get access to the
police station he kills anyone and
everyone in his way to get to Jill's
holding cell Hoffman places Jill in the
reverse bear trap which kills her and
prepares to get away however he's met
outside by three men in pig masks one of
them is Dr Gordon who's seeking
retaliation for Jill Gordon shackles
Hoffman to Adam's old spot in the
bathroom and takes away the saw that
would allow him to save himself game
over
no 10 years after John Kramer's death a
series of jigsaw-like deaths occur the
bodies are analyzed by Logan and a
strangely jigsaw obsessed assistant
Eleanor detective howerin is drawn into
the case by a former criminal named
Edgar Munson who shows up with a remote
device alerts the police and later turns
up dead little does howerin know he's
been set up by Logan howerin is a
crooked detective who took a bribe from
mson the man who murdered Logan's wife
the game is a copycat version of the
test Logan survived Logan plants puzzle
pieces of the new victims in hen's
freezer so that his partner Keith hunt
will suspect howerin elanar is also
poised to be a witness to hanin's
culpability after she and Logan arrive
at the side of the game she escapes in
Ambush by howerin and runs for help
Logan forces howerin to admit his
misdeeds by pretending to be trapped in
a two-person test with him but after
halin confesses Logan reveals that he
has taped him he watches as hain's head
is sliced to pieces in the laser collar
Trap game over for now in spiral which
takes place a few years later a
policeman is attacked by an as salent
wearing a pig mask and suspended by his
tongue in the Subway tunnel a recorded
message informs the off-duty officer
that he will have to either sever his
tongue or be hit by the next train he's
unable to escape in time and is killed
detective Zeke Banks recognizes the
murder as something straight out of the
jigsaw Killer's Playbook and begins
investigating this apparent copycat
detective Banks salvation was offered
but it was
declined things these JS are even got a
doll this time Zeke comes Under
Suspicion himself when the next officer
to be targeted is someone he had a
grievance with it only gets wor worse
when a piece of tattooed skin belonging
to his latest partner the young rookie
William shank arrives at the station in
a box alongside a pig puppet it becomes
apparent that the Killer is interested
in Zeke when shank's skinned body is
discovered in a butcher shop that used
to be a hobby store a place Zeke
frequently visited as a boy after
learning about the cas Zeke's father
Marcus decides to get involved but by
doing so he's playing right into the
Killer's hands he follows the bread
Trail to a warehouse where he's swiftly
abducted he's soon joined in the
warehouse by Zeke who gets kidnapped
shortly after when Zeke wakes up in the
warehouse he's chained to a pipe with a
hacksaw nearby of course he knows
exactly what this means he actually
entertains the idea of sawing his hand
off but thankfully he's able to use a
bobby pin to free himself without any
maming he then discovers Peter dunlee
his former partner chained up dun Ley
was a dirty cop who went down after he
murdered a man he's about to be killed
by a glass Shard launching device unless
Zeke saves him Zeke tries to free him
but he can't beat the trap in time
there's an even bigger surprise waiting
for Zeke in the Next Room his most
recent partner shank alive and well he
faked his death and has actually been
the copycat killer all along much to
Zeke's astonishment it turns out that
shank's name is really Emerson and he's
the son of the man dun leevy killed
Emerson reveals that Zeke's father
protected crooked cops like dun leevy
during his time in charge because he was
so hellbent on cleaning up the streets
regardless of collateral damage it's at
this point that Emerson reveals Zeke's
final test he hands the cop a gun with
one bullet and tells him that he can
either kill him or shoot a Target that
will free his father who is slowly being
drained of his blood Zeke shoots the
target but when a SWAT team previously
called by Emerson arrives they trigger a
trip wire and Marcus's trap reacts by
making it appear as though he's pointing
a weapon the SWAT team shoots Marcus
dead right in front of a devastated Zeke
in the confusion Emerson Slips
[Music]
Away